voilà donc ça devrait
de Micheline nous allons vous avions
reçu donc au Palais du Luxembourg
l'autre de votre dernier passage à Paris
en octobre dernier je tiens à vous
remercier monsieur le Président d'avoir
accepté le présent entretien car à
l'époque n'avait pas encore eu le temps
de pouvoir prendre connaissance
pleinement du questionnaire adressé sur
l'évolution institutionnelle souhaitable
pour votre territoire si elle était
votre désir j'avais eu l'occasion de
souligner combien celui-ci est atypique
au sein de la République bien évidemment
et nous sommes heureux de vous donner la
possibilité de vous exprimer à ce sujet
vous pourrez ainsi nous dire si un
consensus se dessine aujourd'hui en
faveur d'un nouveau statut d'une
évolution souhaitée ce que vous en
attendez le cas échéant nous achevons
ces jours-ci avec ma collègue Mr Jack
cooporteur notre cycle d'audition sur
ces perspectives d'évolution
institutionnelle et nous devrons rendre
un rapport en janvier prochain en tout
cas au premier trimestre de l'année 2023
je vais vous céder la parole monsieur le
Président pour un exposé éliminaire
d'une dizaine de minutes
sachant qu'un questionnaire vous a été
adressé puis ce que je vous proposerai
par la suite c'est de pouvoir revenir au
travers du questionnaire c'est un
exercice assez libre sur tout ce qui est
intéressant c'est de pouvoir avoir un
retour écrit à un moment donné de ce
questionnaire pour nourrir notre rapport
et puis de pouvoir aborder cette
audition de manière très simple et très
fluide au travers de ce que vous avez
envie de nous passer comme message et
puis je laisserai évidemment la parole
également à missing Jack et on vous
interrogera par la suite donc monsieur
le Président vous avez la parole
[Applaudissements]
qui est président
de cette commission
à peu près
et merci également bien sûr de votre
présence
donc je me présente je suis monsieur
monitoris
président de l'Assemblée territoriale et
nous venons tout juste de
lire bien sûr le nouveau bureau de
l'Assemblée territoriale et donc je suis
reparti pour
pour
l'année 2023 en tant que président de
l'Assemblée territoriale et je suis à
côté de moi c'est le nouveau
vice-président de l'Assemblée
territoriale et bien sûr monsieur
voilà président
des salutations
j'avais souhaité vous présenter depuis
les salutations les plus cordiales et
respectueuse
et je vous propose de rentrer dans le
vif du sujet chers Président je sais pas
si vous souhaitez qu'on qu'on passe à
travers les quelques questions qu'on
vous adressez ou si vous avez des propos
un peu plus libres que vous voulez nous
donner en introduction sinon on peut
rentrer tout de suite dans cette dans
cette audition bien évidemment sur le
sujet d'intérêt sur lequel le Sénat est
à nouveau regard
d'accord monsieur le président
notre entretien de la dernière fois lors
de
mon passage
à Paris avec une délégation des lieux et
donc nous nous sommes revenus qu'on
allait bien sûr venir puis essayer de
réfléchir et de vous apporter des
réponses par rapport au questionnaires
que vous nous aviez transmis
et donc je pense que je vais rentrer
directement plutôt
avec grand plaisir Président vous avez
la main et puis on passe à travers
tranquillement et puis on échange on
vous interpellera enfin volant on fait
les choses de manière interactive que ça
se fasse de manière fluide on a de vous
entendre évidemment sur sur ce sujet
et donc concernant la première question
de
photographe depuis
197961 et qui est le seul
territoire de l'article 74 de la
Constitution à ne pas avoir vu son
statut évolué depuis la révision
d'institutionnelle 2003 souhaitez-vous
une réponse de la de la loi du 29
juillet 1961
donc c'est à dire que plusieurs
tentatives de réforme ou d'amélioration
de la loi statutaire du 29 juillet 1961
ont été nommés depuis 1976
mais elles sont toujours restés belles
en raison d'une certaine hostilité et
méfiance des autorités qui bien
altération de leur prérogative quand on
redoute renforcement des pouvoirs des
autorités politiques et administratives
à noter que lors des Assises des
Outre-mer lancer en novembre 2017 l'un
des sous thèmes de réflexion compter sur
la situation juridique et
institutionnelle du territoire
en 2019 la sorte de territoriale a créé
un groupe de travail dénommé à venir
institutionnel de la de l'Assemblée
territoriale avec commission
de relancer les travaux sur localisation
est-ce que
l'Assemblée territoriale et sur le
statut de l'élu
les travaux ont été suspendus durant la
crise sanitaire mais ils n'ont pas
repris depuis
là il faut dire que l'actuel assemble
les territoriale dans
avec la majorité actuelle
une évolution
mais juste pour apporter des
modifications particulières
mais pour une récente totale du statut
on est on est réservé sur sur ça
voilà pour la première question
comme je non mais juste non mais on va
continuer président juste vous dire ce
qu'on a déjà dit d'ailleurs quand on a
reçu avec Michelin qui est le président
Larcher les maires outre-mer il y a
quelques jours maintenant et Micheline
animait cette table ronde sur
l'évolution institutionnelle c'est
effectivement premièrement constaté que
nos territoires ont tous des besoins
différents y compris en termes
d'évolution donc ce que vous nous dites
là si vous voulez correspond
effectivement à une réalité qu'on
rencontre sur d'autres territoires
certains veulent aller plus loin
d'autres pas du tout certains veulent
effectivement faire comme vous le faites
à l'instant donc tout ça effectivement
ça ça va dans le sens du message porté
par par le Sénat donc je vous en prie on
peut continuer si vous voulez
le statut actuel pour la question de
le statut actuel facilité la conduite de
politique publique efficace alors
seulement bloque-t-il certaines actions
et vous juger indispensables
si c'est nous des exemples
donc le fait que le représentant de
l'État soit également l'exécutif du
territoire est un frein à la conduite
des politiques publiques efficaces il ne
s'agit nullement ici de compétences il
s'agit de dissocier les deux
institutions pour que le représentant de
l'État exerce pleinement ces missions
relatives à l'état et que l'exécutif fut
détenu par une entité locale exerce
également pleinement ces missions en
faveur du territoire en concertation
avec l'État
et non sous l'autorité de l'État
voilà pour la deuxième question la
réponse que je peux vous apporter
concernant la deuxième question
merci merci Président on peut mettre ton
passé sur le volet des compétences on a
déjà un premier élément de réponse sur
les modalités d'exercice que vous
souhaitez et ça correspond aussi un peu
aux échanges que nous avions eu on
aparté de notre première rencontre mais
sur le fait que vous constatiez
effectivement vous souhaitiez pouvoir
être pleinement décisionnaire en
concertation et pas sous l'autorité et
donc effectivement ça peut amener le
sujet de nouvelles compétences dans de
nouveaux domaines par exemple c'est la
troisième question ou à l'inverse est-ce
que vous avez vous identifié d'ores et
déjà ou peut-être dans des réflexions à
venir des compétences que vous
souhaiteriez au contraire restituer à
l'État dans le cadre d'un nouveau
partenariat qui pourrait être qui
pourrait être créé
et donc la répartition actuelle des
compétences semble satisfaisant
tout simplement en raison du manque de
capacité locale
en ressources humaines que financière
par exemple en matière de santé et
d'enseignement
là les réponses que je peux
vous apporter par rapport à la troisième
question
d'accord et au vu donc de l'expérience
que vous en avez maintenant et
félicitations évidemment pour votre
réélection puisque ça faisait partie
également des discussions que nous
avions eu ensemble la dernière fois
est-ce que vous diriez que le principe
de spécialité vous apporte une garantie
d'une meilleure adaptation des textes
nationaux à votre contexte local ou
est-ce que les extensions d'adaptation
des textes votés dans l'Hexagone à
Wallis sont discutés en détail avec les
autorités locales ou est-ce que voilà
est-ce qu'il y a des échanges avant même
qu'une loi par exemple ou un display un
dispositif national s'applique chez vous
parce que le principe le spécialité
législatives
devraient effectivement garantir une
meilleure adaptation des textes
nationaux aux spécificités locales dans
la pratique la vie de la somme de
territoriale et sollicité mais les
données pour se prononcer sans souvent
souvent on demande de recueillir la vie
de la terre selon la procédure d'urgence
il arrive aussi que l'assemblée se
retrouve avec le Rapport au Président de
la République pour l'exposer des motifs
alors de la transmission du projet de
texte devrait être automatiquement
accompagné de ce document et au stade de
la consultation ont les mêmes passions
que nos demandes de modifications sont
prises en compte il y a ensuite un
travail à réaliser avec les
parlementaires pour la suite après
monsieur le principe de spécialités
législatives sera efficace la procédure
doit être améliorée à l'hôtel également
de l'Assemblée territoriale a également
mis en place une commission interne des
affaires juridiques
et de la réglementation chargée
d'instruire les projets de textes à vos
présentations à la commission permanente
pour délibération pour en session
plénière
est-ce que est-ce que selon vous dans
dans l'organisation actuelle ou à venir
président
il faudrait revoir l'articulation du
pouvoir coutumier
on sait qu'évidemment ça revient à un
point important et vous l'avez rappelé
en introduction et comment est-ce que ça
pourrait s'articuler si il fallait
modifier ou est-ce que pour vous la
place du pouvoir coutumier doit rester
la même que celle d'aujourd'hui dont
l'organisation telle que vous la
souhaitez
les compétences
déjà de l'Assemblée
sur l'article carotte du décret numéro
57 du 22 juillet 19557
pour information
la santé territoriale va
lors de la de cette session budgétaire
pour que cet article 40 était très 57
soit modifié afin d'arroger les
dispositions relatives
on sait qu'il relève de la compétence
déchetterie quotidienne hormis donc le
foncier les compétences normatives de la
somme des territoriale concerne le
statut de la fonction publique était
territoriale l'agriculture les forêts la
protection des sols la protection de la
nature et des végétaux la lutte plutôt
sanitaire la plus maritime
sauf la préfecture il y a le soutien à
la production le transport terrestre de
tourisme le régime des bourses
subventions secours le sport l'aide
sociale et la fiscalité
si donc si on va maintenant sur le rôle
de l'État donc les relations entre votre
collectivité et l'État ce sont les
questions 8 et les questions neufs donc
si j'ai bien pardon
des institutions on peut continuer si
vous le voulez notamment sur
l'articulation avec le pouvoir coutumier
c'était la question 7 si vous avez mais
on a un début de réponse dans ce que
vous avez dit mais effectivement si vous
voulez aller plus loin dans la réflexion
c'est-à-dire que là actuellement
l'Assemblée territoriale avec souvent
les propositions de
je vous je vous fais un peu un peu de
situations par rapport à la à
l'Assemblée territoriale puisque un
homme de conseillers c'est-à-dire
en effet thoriaux et un chiffre paires
peut présenter également des des
difficultés pratiques dans le
fonctionnement de notre institution
notamment lors de l'élection du bureau
ou parfois quand il y a égalité des mois
on a recours à la règle du candidat le
plus âgé on peut proposer de porter le
nombre de conseillers
à 21 voir à 21 élus ajouter
pour faire un empereur
il y a la durée aussi du mandat du
président de son bureau actuellement
d'un an et de favorise pas la stabilité
et l'efficacité de l'action de l'équipe
dirigeante
les élus ne disposent pas non plus
d'outils juridiques pour renverser le
bureau de la santé
aucun de désherbrovation de la politique
le renouvellement des membres du bureau
de l'Assemblée territoriale de la
commission permanente a lieu tous les
ans après l'ouverture de la session
budgétaire il n'est plus contester que
cette situation a souvent à la source
d'instabilité politique qui empêche
souvent le bureau de s'inscrire dans une
perspective de développement à moyen ou
à long terme on pourrait porter cette
durée à
la mise en oeuvre d'une possibilité de
restitution du bureau de l'Assemblée
pour l'Administration du territoire et
des amis notamment tous les projets qui
doivent être soumis à l'assemblée
territoriale
les trois membres nommés par
l'administrateur supérieur du territoire
après accord de l'Assemblée territoriale
et parmi les citoyens français
jouissance de leur droit civils et
politiques ou de leur suppléance
territoriale normalement c'est nous
avons une aussi un projet de
délibération pour un être un peu
justement pour pour
demander à ce que les membres nommés par
l'administrateur supérieur après apport
de l'assemblé territoriale soit au
nombre de 5 au lieu de 3
afin que les sept séquences électorales
soient représentées au sein de cette
importance de cette importante
institution voilà ça ça aussi
nous avons également
un peu
de libération pour augmenter le nombre
de
représentants de la partie civile
merci pour ces précisions présidents et
si on revient maintenant au rôle de
l'État est-ce que vous considérez
que les moyens de l'État aujourd'hui
sont sur votre territoire sont
pleinement adaptés justement dans
évidemment les domaines de compétences
de l'État sont pleinement adaptés aux
besoins exprimés par votre territoire
avant parce que
on se partage avec le vice-président des
tâches je vais vous laisser de
vous apporter des réponses par rapport
au rôle de l'État
apôtre pour
terminer avec avec le pouvoir continuer
on souhaiterait aussi le président
compte du pouvoir continuer et parce que
c'est
fondamental et que la coutume et le
socle des cultures des photos d'elle
et donc
cette question doit être
traitée avec avec les chiffres
voilà et je laisse la suite à mon
collègue président
voilà merci
Google
depuis deux jours voilà donc je continue
donc par la question numéro 8 sur donc
souhaitez-vous que le pouvoir exécutif
la transférer du représentants de l'État
identité locale
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il existe à large
consensus pour que le pouvoir
du représentant de l'État local mais
est-ce que ce sera une entité locale
élue donc c'est la question qui est
posée et donc sur les modalités
notamment et les formes de transfert de
l'exécutif local dans le respect et la
préservation du rôle des chefs coutumier
ça reste quand même un élément important
de notre organisation sociale donc il
faut absolument prendre en compte cette
situation qui est très particulière mais
qui permet de préserver la paix sociale
ici et donc c'est un élément important
qu'on se parle préserver dans le cadre
au niveau du son futur et de transmettre
l'exécutifs
écartés ou minimiser dans ce cadre là
sur la question numéro 9
donc sur la déconcentration donc voilà
la prise de propres politiques voilà
donc il y a un contexte local juridique
économique sociale voilà la fréquence de
concentration donc là pour l'instant
nous au niveau du territoire avant que
ce qu'on souhaitait donc c'est que les
modifications soient vraiment ciblées
que ça soit pas une refonte de général
de la philosophie du statut du 1961 que
les autorités continuèrent conserver à
l'équilibre général de ce texte donc ce
qui fait que les marges de manoeuvre au
niveau territorial c'est un peu limité
et donc on garde on souhaite garder
l'équilibre qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est
pour ça que c'est difficile de pouvoir
envisager quelque chose de plus profond
et qui déconcentre complètement notre
équilibre politique et économique même
sociale donc c'est pour
faut vraiment le prendre en compte parce
que on peut pas faire autrement ici par
rapport à notre culture
voilà donc sinon je pars à la question
10 qui porte donc sur les la révision
des articles 73 va constitution
donc pour nous
voilà donc il y a donc
font partie donc des
donc la Polynésie française était
Barthélemy Saint-Martin voilà qui sont
donc voilà 74 il me semble voilà donc
l'assemblée territoire
donc de spécialité législatives et
autonomie et tout dépendante de la
rédaction du nouvel article qui
fusionnerait les articles 113 et 74 donc
je sais pas si c'est envisagé dans le
cadre de la révision de prévu voilà mais
nous on souhaite garder en fait les ces
deux principales
spécialité législatives et d'autonomie
de notre collectivité
voilà
soit la question numéro 11 donc ça porte
sur lequel sens donnez-vous aux notion
de différenciation de responsabilisation
et d'autonomie alors sur la
différenciation à des situations
différentes devront être apportées des
réponses différentes et adaptées aux
contexte local on y tient absolument
parce que nous sommes loin quand on vit
dans un pays pauvre européen on la
France les règles sont adaptées sans
doute économique sociale et culturel
nous on souhaite qu'on garde cette
spécialité c'est de différenciation par
rapport à nos à notre territoire qui est
lointain
dans la responsabilisation c'est lors
des élections donc l'élu mélanger sa
responsabilité politique pour
l'assemblée territoriale de cette notion
responsabilité politique n'est pas
satisfaisante un conseil territoire pour
le territoire composé de deux îles mais
il est peut-être amené dans certains
dossiers à vouloir privilégier tel
projet en raison de sa situation dans sa
circonscription électorale en ce qui
concerne l'autonomie donc la compétence
pour fixer les règles qui ont métropole
relève de la loi donc voilà donc c'est
la compétence en autonomie voilà donc
c'est un sujet aussi
à regarder le prêt voilà sur l'autonomie
nous on parle notre statut nous permet
grâce donc à la présence des autorités
coutumières de disposer une certaine
autonomie vis-à-vis de l'extérieur donc
c'est pour ça que sur cette question
nous n'avons pas de
de l'idée spécifique par rapport à ça
voilà sur la question numéro 12 donc
l'article 114 de la construction permet
la d'option par les autonomie de mesure
justifiées par l'industrie locale en
matière taxé à l'emploi le 3
établissement pour exercice la
protection du patrimoine financier
souhaiteriez-vous bénéficier de ces
dispositions protectrices oui dans le
respect de la préservation du rôle des
chefs coutumières nous souhaitons que
cette de cette notion donc de préserver
nos autorités
la question numéro 13 est donc sur des
souhaits d'évolution associés dans le
départ public qu'en est-il des
socioprofessionnelles de révision
constitutions
par Monsieur le Président donc c'est un
dossier qui est très sensible ici
qui doit faire l'objet de réunion de
travail de concertation avec les
différentes autorités du territoire donc
c'est une question qui est élaborée
évoqué tous les jours parce que
toujours des partenaires considèrent que
notre statut ou nos autorités
coutumières Fresnes développement mais
je crois que la contrepartie c'est notre
stabilité sociale qui n'a pas de prix et
je pense que quand on va ce qui se passe
dans les autres pour l'activités on peut
quand même
penser que notre organisation est
efficace de ce point de vue là
dans la dernière question donc
c'est un amendement directement inspiré
de travaux de Michel va avait été
présenté lors de l'examen
il reprendait les dispositions de cette
proposition de rédaction là je crois que
là pour nous on a passé le on n'a pas pu
avoir cette disposition désolé mais si
vous pouvez nous dire de quoi il s'agit
on pourrait peut-être vous répondre
bonjour monsieur le Président et toutes
mes félicitations pour votre élection
bonjour monsieur le nouveau conseiller
territorial adjoint et pareil je vous
adresse mes sincères félicitations donc
pour revenir à la question la
proposition de de rédaction
en fait pour l'instant entre l'article
73 et 74 il n'y a pas de il n'y a pas de
lien et l'objectif c'est de pouvoir
créer pour chaque territoire ultramarin
un statut à la carte qui serait régie
par une loi organique donc où vous
pourriez mettre
tout ce qui que vous souhaitez pour
votre territoire vous avez beaucoup
insisté sur
le pouvoir coutumier donc c'est
l'opportunité de pouvoir co-construire
avec avec l'État avec le pouvoir
coutumier ce que vous souhaitez pour
votre territoire pour votre collectivité
et je tiens aussi à souligner que le
rôle du ciné ce n'est pas devenu vous
imposer quoi que ce soit mais au
contraire être à votre écoute donc voilà
en gros ce qui est prévu on ne
toucherait pas à la spécialité
législative il n'y a pas de remodulation
complète et de perte de vos spécificités
de vos acquis
pour en revenir à ce que vous avez
évoqué sur le pouvoir l'exécutif est-ce
que vous avez déjà eu des échanges avec
les tests que l'État serait prêt à
laisser
à vous laisser un peu plus de marge de
manœuvre manière d'exécutif et une
deuxième question alors je vous
laisserai répondre ou j'enchaîne une
autre question ce serait aussi sur
l'application du pouvoir coutumier
est-ce que vous avez réfléchi à Conseil
exécutif qui pourrait avoir une partie
coutumière et une partie d'élus voir
comment comment vous avez vous penserez
une articulation de manière à voir
que tout le monde soit entendu
voilà je crois par rapport à la première
question je crois que l'État attend bien
évidemment n'est pas défavorable à la
transfert de l'exécutif sur les échanges
il y a aucun souci de ce côté là par
rapport à la question donc de
l'organisation d'une nouvelle exécutif
éventuellement si jamais ça devait
revenir au niveau politique je crois que
l'idée qui est maintenant
admise mais c'est pas encore tout à fait
validé c'est que en fait on conserve le
comment on appelle ça le conseil du
territoire dans lequel aujourd'hui siège
les trois rois
ainsi que les membres nommés et donc par
l'administrateur super sur proposition
de l'Assemblée territoriale ça pourrait
être un début donc c'est à dire que
c'est juste le représentant de l'état
d'une
mais la composition du conseil
territorial qui fonctionne très très
bien en termes d'échanges par rapport au
pouvoir coutumier qui permet donc
d'avoir une certaine transparence au
niveau des décisions
donc c'est ce qui est un petit peu
envisagé mais la variction n'est pas
aboutit du tout puisque ça reste quand
même comme vous êtes présents tout à
l'heure quelque chose de difficile
localement donc il faut qu'on arrive à
convaincre tout le monde de l'intérêt de
passer à ce stade là voilà mais en tout
cas on y travaille et puis voilà en gros
c'est un peu ça c'est en chamboule pas
l'équilibre qui est prévu dans le statut
de santé c'est juste que les personnes
qui sont désignées pour exercer les
fonctions d'exécutif qui vont changer ça
sera quelqu'un de
d'ici d'élus et ça sera plus le
représentant de l'État
je vous remercie pour pour ces éléments
de réponse donc vous souhaitez pour
conclure avoir plus de prise de décision
localement
pour adapter
les lois les règlements
spécificités de votre territoire tout en
intégrant les différentes composantes de
votre de votre organisation interne
c'est notre souhait
mais comparaison nous avons une autre
un autre projet de libération que nous
allons bien sûr
en débattre lors de cette session pour
la
représentativité du territoire
à l'extérieur
par exemple au niveau régional
ça c'est
un problème qui nous
préoccupe parce que les
sujets qui sont débattus lors des
conférences
international
relève quand même
de
d'échanges purement politique
le fait que
nous suivons le statut qui stipule bien
que c'est
nos relations céréales on aime bien de
la compétence de l'État
mais dans la pratique et dans la réalité
ce n'est pas ça mais donc
à ce que le préfet
représente le territoire dans l'eau
relation
inter régionales avec les autres régions
du Pacifique
pour nous c'est
on n'est pas satisfait à ça donc
le brevet de l'opération il va être
présenté en session c'est justement pour
mettre un peu à ce que l'État même si
c'est de sa compétences nous donnent
quand même c'est cette ouverture
justement pour que les élus puissent
représenter le territoire au niveau
régional dans les conférences dans les
dans les forums voilà et parce que c'est
quand même des débats
qui sont des débats politiques
voilà et
ça rejoint ça rejoint justement le
souhait bien sûr des
élus pour
pour cette évolution là
et pour la somme je l'avais indiqué
tout à l'heure
on est un peu réservé sur
une éventuel changement
dans l'immédiat
notre statut on préfère
aller étape par étape évoluer bien sûr
mais
doucement mais sûrement voilà
justement le sens de la proposition de
Michel du rapport de Michel Magra c'est
d'ouvrir le champ des possibles et de
permettre justement cette évolution
étape par étape à adapter à chaque
territoire donc c'est vraiment le point
sur lequel Michel Magrin insistait
beaucoup parce que tous les territoires
sont différents on est problématiques
différentes et aspire sont plus ou moins
pour certains prêts à évoluer d'autres
ont besoin de plus de temps et l'idée
c'est que les uns ne freinent pas les
autres que chacun puisse évoluer à son
rythme donc c'est le sens même de cette
proposition
en tout cas sachez que
les choses sont sont très claires en
tout cas et les aspirations légitimes
que vous avez exprimées rejoignent celle
de beaucoup d'élus et notamment la
représentativité des élus à l'extérieur
du territoire quand il y a des quand
vous évoluez dans votre environnement
régional ça correspond à des choses
qu'on a déjà entendues bien évidemment
et qui sont dans la tête de beaucoup
d'élus et que vous trouverez évidemment
toujours au Sénat des parlementaires
désirés de vous accompagner dans ce
processus et attentif évidemment assez
recommandations qui figureront bien
évidemment dans le rapport que nous
serons à émettre avec avec michine
Jacques et que j'aurai le plaisir de
rapporter dans le groupe
décentralisation en tout cas nous
restons évidemment attentifs et désireux
de pouvoir collecter vos différentes
délibérations qui émettent ces souhaits
d'évolution statutaire sur les
différents éléments que vous avez évoqué
monsieur le Président et Monsieur le
vice-président et nous tenions avec
vous remercier de la qualité de cet
échange
on vous souhaitant évidemment de
fructueux travaux
puisque des groupes de travail vont être
mis en oeuvre et on ne doute pas que
vous arriverez à en sortir quelque chose
de fondamental pour votre territoire en
terme d'évolution mais ce que je vois
déjà et l'expression que vous en avez
faites traduit une volonté très forte de
une aspiration à une autonomie
responsabilisation également une
application des élus notamment dans leur
environnement régional donc merci la
qualité de ces échanges messieurs et et
bonne fin de journée en ce qui vous
concerne puisque nous vend quelques
heures de décalage et merci de votre
grande disponibilité merci à vous
je propose de clôturer l'audition
maintenant messieurs
je vous propose de clôturer l'audition
sur face que vous vouliez conclure
chaque président
oui
déjà vous avez un pays comme les
éléments
dont vous avez besoin pour faire votre
rapport
et donc moi avec le vice-président
maintenant quand même aussi à vous
remercier de votre écoute et
on vous souhaite une très bonne
continuation et très bonne journée pour
vos travaux
merci messieurs à très bientôt au revoir